y la promesa del presidente ucraniano de
recuperarla crimea anexada a rusia es
considerada por el kremlin como una
amenaza directa mientras tanto eeuu la
otan y europa han advertido
repetidamente a moscú sobre las
consecuencias de emprender acciones
militares en ucrania pero ahora aumentan
los temores en occidente sobre una
posible invasión rusa con sporting con
el espíritu de ser claro y sincero que
es lo mejor que se puede hacer si rusia
decide perseguir el enfrentamiento habrá
graves consecuencias a finales de
octubre comenzaron a aparecer vídeos en
las redes sociales que mostraban tropas
tanques y misiles rusos trasladándose
hacia la frontera con ucrania quien dice
que más de 90 mil soldados rusos se han
reunido allí mientras que moscú lo acusa
de perseguir su propia consolidación
militar un despliegue militar ruso
similar ocurrió en primavera aunque
moscú se retiró después de que vladimir
putin y joe biden anunciaron que se
reunirían algunos expertos especulan que
la actividad militar estaba destinada a
obtener ese beneficio diplomático y que
rusia podría estar empleando actualmente
la misma
lo que es seguro es que el kremlin está
haciendo oír sus líneas rojas sobre todo
la de una posible expansión de la otan
hacia el este de ucrania
rusia le está exigiendo garantías
legales a esa organización después de
condenar los recientes ejercicios
militares de eeuu y la otan en el mar
negro así como el envío de armamento a
ucrania desde occidente eeuu teme que
rusia pueda utilizar cualquier supuesta
provocación occidental como pretexto
para la acción militar analistas dicen
que una invasión rusa a ucrania no
beneficiaría a vladimir putin ya que
significaría ocupar un país de 45
millones de habitantes la mayoría de los
cuales reciente era moscú